the tropicana hosts a wine and spirit
series and this week it's hosted by red
lotus asian kitchen and joining me to
tell us all about the sake tasting and
dinner is chef steven leung and from tea
and beverage aaron dice welcome you guys
so great to see you i love this spread
let's talk about the food first chef
tell us about the red lotus experience
so uh first of all i'm chef steven from
detroit canada and today we're promoting
our sake tasting dinner
soon this friday so the thought process
behind the menu i read lotus is uh we
want to bring a little bit of everything
around all asian regions yeah and um so
it's actually a very good you know very
very good deal because it's a four
course dinner but you're actually
getting the first appetizer you get
three bites of each so we have the
chicken one time here with like a yuzu
mustard glaze oh nice and then um
this tofu salad roll we're going to
dress it with a peanut and sesame
dressing so you get a little citrus and
also that nutty flavor from the dressing
and also this right here is actually a
piece of chinese donut it's not sweet so
it's not sweet it's a fried dough and
then we stuff it with um a scallop paste
and we deep fry it so it's it's called a
scalloped toast that seems like enough
for me just the appetizer but then you
go on and you have a soup and you have
meat and then you have it looks like you
have a noodle dish here so actually um
we're gonna this is the first course the
appetizer and then we're gonna follow
that with uh a shrimp bisque so with
kimchi inside kimchi kimchi shrimp brisk
and then we have a grilled uh tiger
prawns uh to accomplish with the with
the soup and actually when we move to
the to the main course um we can choose
a vegetarian option so it's a mixed
vegetable mixed vegetable and mix uh a
mushroom uh sauce with a pan-fried
noodle or you go with uh the flat iron
steak
mongolian style with a company with the
chow mein
okay you have options we love that and
also what we love is that you're pairing
it up with sake right tell us a little
bit aaron about this what what is sake
for those that don't know so sake is a
lightly alcoholic beverage that's brewed
from rice
so what we want to do is basically
showcase sake in the sense of handling
much like wine so that's why i've served
the sake in a wine glass i love it chef
and it's typically when you see people
drink sake it's like in a little white
yes yeah so usually they're using
smaller shot vessels okay
in a way it defeats the purpose it is a
very traditional way to serve sake but
at the same time if we're talking
aromatics and flavor profile you kind of
miss a little bit of that if you're just
shooting it from chef's already down in
here
he's on it so kampai
all right now do you swirl it like yes
you treat it like a glass of wine okay
so so the purpose of using the stem
glassware this is actually a custom made
glass that i had uh procured from china
specific for sake so it's a smaller bulb
smaller than a white wine glass and then
we're serving the sake chilled uh which
is uh more common for a craft uh high
quality sake so yeah so you want to
swirl specialize in high quality yes
ma'am
let's give it a swirl
treat it like a glass of wine so you
swirl put your nose there it smells nice
this is a very earthy sake so i'll warn
you ahead of time this is you know a
little bit more of an acquired taste but
great accompaniment for the the dishes
so
the sake itself i wanted to showcase the
dishes so i wanted the sake to kind of
play second fiddle this is so just
really nice it is kind of
i don't want to use the word thick but
there is like a it's a little richer
heartier it's hearty that's great so if
you want to be a part of this tasting
over at red lettuce tell us how do
people become a part of this
chef so um
first of all uh with the parent
parenting side aaron did a great job of
you know
pairing the favorite profile so you take
a bite
of everything yeah you could take a bite
i mean everyone uh one bite we're gonna
we're gonna go crazy on this yeah and
actually we're running out of time so i
want to make sure we get the details how
do people do that to go to the website
and make sure so we can go to the box
office or the website it's uh ninety
dollars per person or uh right now we
have a special of 160 for two so
do it you gotta check it out this is
amazing thank you guys so much for
joining us we'll be right back
you